we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we are going to go next to our caller
from the 7 1 4 area code caller from 7 1
4 who's this hello can you hear me
yes we can yes hi so my name is kyondra
I'm just calling because um as we
approach the primaries out the year the
day everybody's talking about there
being some sort of um blue wave and as a
progressive I'm not sure how truthful
how certain I am that you know Trump has
scared the country so to say for lack of
a better term yep into the left or into
the blue wave how certain are you that
we'll see this dynamic shift in Congress
and in their Senate as far as you know
the blue a you are 100% right I share
your skepticism about this blue wave if
there is going to be a natural blue wave
that's coming and that's that's going to
be it that's great will benefit from it
but I think that there should not even
be a moment of resting back on the idea
that there is this definitive blue wave
coming we need to be getting out the
vote in every single race there needs to
be a complete and and singular focus on
the 2018 midterms as if they are not
going to go well for the left and I
think any there's absolutely no benefit
to believing that there's a blue wave
coming right if it's true that it is
great but there is only the potential to
not do enough if you believe there is
this inevitable blue wave so I think
you're spot on and because I think that
also just to comment my last comment on
it I think that the what happened in
Alabama but the road more thing and the
Dow Jones is I think I was a really one
in a million needle-in-a-haystack sort
of case I just think that was a shot in
the dark
and we got that but I don't think the
Democrats you you know rest I don't
think we should be wrestling at all
thinks we should be on this this midterm
absolutely if I mean that was a
completely unique case and if it is
representative of what's coming in
November great I don't know that it
tells us that it is at all so I think
you're spot-on and I appreciate the call
thank you